we all remember jurassic park steven
spielberg's 1993 dinosaur epic about the
dangers of leaving newman in charge of
your security
special effects were a big deal at the
time due in large part to this man my
name is michael lantery i designed these
special dinosaur effects on jurassic
park and while that included epic scenes
with the raptors and the t-rex there was
one special effect sequence that proved
a lot more challenging than the rest it
was the rippling water in the cup inside
the car
where'd that idea come from in the first
place
one day a steven spielberg called me
from his car and said
that he was listening to earth wind and
fire in his view mirror was shaking
that's what has to happen when the t-rex
arrives as well as that i want to have a
cup of water and i want to have the
water ripple that's the way we're going
to see the arrival to the t-rex this
kicked off three weeks of long days and
sleepless nights for michael and his
team
turns out making those perfect circles
was a lot harder than you might expect
what he really wanted was exact
timed
concentric rings starting from the
center moving its way out so the obvious
is is you know when you throw a rock
into a pond you get that so we drop
something into the
cup and of course it does it
now we had the issue of
you see what we're dropping that steven
did not want to see we kept trying
everything and just i kept shooting
video and showing steven and we didn't
quite get there this all changed one
fateful evening a few days before
shooting the scene one night i was up
late with my son
and we were playing with one of my
guitars
i had a drink that i set on top of the
face of the guitar and we were plucking
and playing with it and i noticed that
the
water began to ripple
michael had found his solution
so i took a guitar string and ran it
through the cup through the dashboard of
the car through the floorboard of the
car and tuned it and when we plucked the
string the water began to ripple and
what did steven have to say when stephen
saw the cup ripple he had a big smile
and he just says that is now the arrival
of the t-rex michael antieri and the
rest of the special effects team went on
to win an academy award for their work
on jurassic park and i'm sure it was all
because of those perfect concentric
water ripples
you